tous les Algériens savent
qu'ils ont ainsi le moyen de disposer de
même
à mesure de l'apaisement
merci Monsieur les photographes de vos
beaux fils
mesdames messieurs je me félicite de
vous voir une fois de plus
dans des circonstances importantes
dans un cadre qui a pu quelque peu
changer
la crise ouverte
à propos de Berlin par la Russie
soviétique
plonge l'univers
dans une lourde inquiétude
trois questions
étroitement liées
sont posés par Moscou
éventualité de mesure
qui porterait obstacle
au mouvement des éléments militaires
américains anglais français
entre Berlin Ouest et la zone
occidentale
destin du peuple allemand
qui se trouverait mis en cause
par la séparation formelle de
l'Allemagne en deux états
et par le fait que l'ancienne capitale
du Reich
serait un corporé
au territoire placé sous dictature
autoritaire et totalitaire
ou bien
serait soumise à des conditions qu'il
amènerait à cette servitude
enfin
désarmement en Europe d'une zone
englobante et essentiellement
l'Allemagne
ajoutons que le gouvernement soviétique
en pressant les occidentaux dans ta main
des négociations
sur le sort affaire à Berlin et sur un
traité de paix a concluent avec les deux
Allemagnes
a fait connaître qu'il envisageait
de transmettre au système de pancoff les
droits et les responsabilités qu'il
exerce en ce qui concerne la ville
dans cette hypothèse
les
occidentaux
verraient pour leurs allées et venus de
troupes
peut-être l'obligation de reconnaître ce
système de pentecov
et si ces Occidentaux
voyaient barrer le passage de Berlin et
qu'il voulait l'ouvrir de force
et bien les troupes soviétiques
stationnés en Allemagne orientale
aurait à faire aux Occidentaux et ces
troupes nous attend déclarés ne sont pas
là pour jouer aux billes
cela étant on pourrait concevoir
que la France
se joignant à l'entreprise de scission
engagés vis-à-vis du peuple allemand
que la France chercha attirer parti de
la crise pour s'attribuer aux dépens de
l'Allemagne
des avantages parallèles à ceux que les
Soviétiques paraissent vouloir obtenir
de leur côté
il y a là une politique que d'autres
ont pu pratiquer
à l'égard d'un voisin malheureux
ce n'est pas notre politique
si l'Allemagne actuelle nous paraissait
dangereuse
alors sans doute
la mémoire des épreuves subies de son
fait et la volonté d'en prévenir le
retour
susciterait-elle nos exigences
mais l'Allemagne actuelle
ne nous menace nullement
nous considérons même
qu'avec ces capacités son énergie ses
ressources elles constituent un élément
essentiel de la vie
et du progrès de l'Europe et du monde
entier
et puis comme il est naturel pour deux
adversaires qui après avoir longtemps
combattu
ont renoncé à s'entendre détruire
la France et l'Allemagne sont décidés à
coopérer
sur ce point
la politique du chancelier Adenauer
coïncide avec l'anneau
et tout récemment monsieur Segny
la confirmé que telle était aussi la
politique de l'Italie
aussi ne nous prêterons-nous à rien
qui puisse porter le peuple allemand au
désespoir
ou bien qu'on promette son Pacifique à
venir
ou bien ruiner l'espérance
qui après tant de choc et de l'arme
s'est levée des deux côtés du Rhin
on pourrait concevoir d'autres parts
que la France
jugea à propos de ne pas se mêler de la
querelle
faute d'avoir les moyens d'action
c'est-à-dire de destruction que possède
les Américains et les Russes
et de pouvoir par conséquent prétendre
imposer sa politique
la France pourrait chercher
à se distraire
de l'actuel conflit et éventuellement de
la guerre
pour la France
cela reviendrait à perdre les raisons de
vivre
pour tâcher de garder la vie
et puis ce serait cette anéanti
l'Alliance atlantique
qui n'existe
que parce que la France en fait partie
dès lors que l'Alliance atlantique
n'existerait pas
rien ne pourrait empêcher
la dictature
soviétique
la domination soviétique de s'étendre
sur toute l'Europe et sur toute
l'Afrique et à partir de là de couvrir
le monde entier rien excepté bien sûr
la guerre atomique générale
et bien
la France préfère
maintenir l'Alliance atlantique
jusqu'au jour où l'avenir de la paix
serait réellement assuré
voilà pourquoi nous pensons
que les États-Unis la Grande-Bretagne et
la France
ne doivent pas accepter que qui que ce
soit
bar le passage
à leur troupe de Berlin
si quelqu'un si certains
voulaient s'opposer au passage qui est
notre droit en vertu de la victoire et
des arrangements d'ailleurs conclu avec
l'Union soviétique
si certains voulaient s'opposer au
passage cela est toujours qui
viendraient les soutenir comme être un
acte style à l'égard des Occidentaux et
serait par conséquent responsable des
chocs qui pourraient s'en suivre
et quant au sort de la ville elle-même
nous constatons que ceux de ses
habitants qui ont la possibilité de
s'exprimer librement sont unanimes à
vouloir qu'elle reste occidentale
pour cette raison et aussi pour d'autres
et nous ne mettrions pas que Berlin fut
livré
à au système de Pentecôte
d'ailleurs ce système
nous ne sommes pas disposés à le
reconnaître comme un État souverain et
indépendant car il n'existe
qu'en raison de l'occupation soviétique
et en vertu si j'ose dire d'une
implacable dictature
nous ne considérons pas sur le même plan
au point de vue des relations
extérieures de la République française
nous ne considérons pas sur le même plan
d'une part
cette organisation arbitraire
et d'autre part la République fédérale
allemande dans tous les citoyens disent
écrivent entendre ce qu'ils veulent vont
et viennent à leur gré désignent en
toute liberté leur représentant et leur
gouvernement la réunification des deux
parties actuellement séparées de
l'Allemagne en une seule Allemagne qui
serait entièrement libre nous paraît
être
le but l'objectif le destin normal du
peuple allemand à condition qu'il ne
remettent pas en cause ces actuelles
frontières de l'ouest de l'Est du Nord
et du Sud
et qu'il se destine à s'encadrer
le jour où ce sera possible
dans une organisation aux contractuelle
de l'Europe pour la coopération de toute
l'Europe pour la coopération pour la
liberté et pour la paix mais en
attendant que cet idéal puisse être
atteint nous pensons
que les deux parties de l'Allemagne
devrait pouvoir multiplier entre elles
les relations et les liens dans tous les
domaines pratiques
les transports les postes l'activité
économique les arts les lettres les
sciences les allives ni les personnes
etc
pourrait nous semble-t-il donner lieu à
des arrangements qui rapprocherait les
Allemands
à l'intérieur de ce que j'appellerais la
chose allemande et qui après tout leur
est commune à tous quelle que soit les
régimes et les différences des
conditions
et quant à ce qui est du désarmement de
l'Allemagne et bien ce dégagement ou des
engagements comme on voudra en lui-même
ne nous dit rien qui vaille
si le désarmement s'appliquait à une
zone qui n'approcherait pas de lourd à
l'OTAN que de l'Atlantique
la France
comment serait-elle couverte
en effet
nous ne voyons pas qui dans cette
hypothèse
pourrait empêcher en cas de conflit à un
adversaire éventuel de traverser d'un
bon ou d'un vol le glacis germanique non
défendu et puis qu'est-ce qui se
resterait comme bande de territoires
entre la Meuse et l'Atlantique
pour y disposer et y mettre en action
les moyens à des occidentaux
assurément nous sommes partisans
déterminés du contrôle et de la
limitation de toutes les armes de guerre
mais
ces dispositions apparemment
humanitaires
et ne saurait conduire
à notre disparition
c'est dire que le désarmement il
faudrait qu'il s'appliqua à une aire
assez large et assez profonde pour que
la France en soit couverte et non point
au contraire exposé
sur ces points là
et peut-être sur d'autres
je ne vois pour ma part
aucune objection de principe à ce que
les négociations s'engagent
monsieur éprouve de Murville se rendrait
donc à une éventuelle Conférence des
ministres des Affaires étrangères
s'il arrivait que cette conférence après
examen approfondi des problèmes
puis dégagé des éléments d'un accord sur
des points importants alors moi-même
ayant à mes côtés le Premier ministre
monsieur Michel Debré je pourrais
prendre tard
à une réunion des personnes qui portent
les responsabilités suprême des grands
états
évidemment
les débats d'un pareil à rayage devrait
être préparé et cette areopage là ne
pourrait délibérer que dans un climat
apaisé
sur ce point je me sens entièrement
d'accord avec ce qu'on a récemment dit
le président Aznavour
dans cette grave occurrence la France
se sent qualifiée pour parler
lucidement et sereinement
et d'abord parce que
aucune concurrence
aucune animosité
ne l'inspire à l'égard du peuple russe
au contraire
elle n'a pour lui qu'une amitié réelle
et traditionnelle
ensuite pour cette raison
quand ce qui concerne l'Allemagne qui
est l'enjeu de la crise
la France a dépassé ses griefs d'antan
et que compte tenu des changements qui
ont été opérés
elle considère cet adversaire d'hier
comme son associé d'aujourd'hui et de
demain
et puis enfin parce que la France elle
n'a pas encore de bons atomiques
et que par conséquent elle n'est pas
comme les trois autres
en proie à la hantise
de lancer le cas échéant c'est bon
d'avant que celle de l'adversaire n'est
plus accomplir leur œuvre
c'est pourquoi une fois encore je dis
que la France envisage la crise actuelle
à sa manière
et avec un partialité
et c'est pourquoi aussi en le disant en
son nom
je suis sûr
d'exprimer la pensée de 2 milliards
d'être humain
en raison et en comparaison
et des risques courus par notre espèce
et puis des immenses taches humaines que
nous pourrions que nous devrions
accomplir tous ensemble
nous pensons
que toute mise en demeure qui serait
adressée aux Occidentaux
en vue d'obtenir des abandons par la
voix de l'intimidation
serait de Dieu et absurde
dès lors que
dans un camp comme dans l'autre tout est
agencé
pour que des moyens de destruction
capables d'anéantir des continents soit
déclenchés en l'espace de quelques
secondes
créer
un état de tension telle
que n'importe quelle erreur ou n'importe
quel incident pourrait déclencher le
cataclysme ce serait un défi
inexpiable porté à la vie de l'humanité
et puis
étant donné
que la grande majorité des hommes sur la
Terre
mènent une existence misérable et que
certains peuples ont ceux qui font
pour le progrès de tous que viennent
faire les histoires
de Berlin Ouest
de pancov et du désengagement allemand
en vérité en notre temps il y a qu'une
seule querelle qui vaille et cette
querelle c'est celle de l'homme c'est
l'homme qui s'agit de sauver
de faire vivre
de développer
nous autres qui vivons
entre l'Atlantique et l'Oural
nous autres qui sommes l'Europe
disposant avec l'Amérique sa fille
des sources et des ressources
principales de la civilisation
manger
nous vêtir nous loger nous chauffer
nous autres qui possédons des mines et
des usines en pleine activité des
campagnes bien cultivées des chemins de
fer ou passent des trains nombreux
des routes encombrés de voitures des
ports remplis de bateau des aérodromes
couverts d'avion
nous autres dans tous les enfants après
l'Italie
qui construisons force université et
laboratoires
qui formons des armées de techniciens et
d'ingénieurs
qui pouvons
voir
entendre lire ce qui est nature à
satisfaire la pensée
nous autres qui avons assez de médecins
assez d'hôpitaux assez médicament
pour combattre la souffrance
pour soigner les malades pour assurer la
vie de la plupart des nouveaux-nés que
ne dressons-nous tous ensemble
l'organisation fraternelle qui prêterait
concours aux autres
que ne mettons nous en commun
un pourcentage de nos matières premières
nos objets fabriqués de nos produits
alimentaires
une fraction de nos techniciens de nos
scientifiques
de nos cadres économiques
une part de nos camions de nos navires
de nos avions pour vaincre la misère
pour développer les ressources et pour
aider le travail des peuples qui sont
moins développés
en comparaison de cela que valent le
demande
les prétentions idéologiques
les ambitions impérialistes les
exigences territoriales qui mènent
l'univers à la mort
voilà semble-t-il un point capital
qui devrait être inscrits à l'ordre du
jour des éventuels conférences est-ouest
si on tombait d'accord sur le principe
il faudrait évidemment
dresser en commun un plan de
d'organisation et de réalisation
au cas où il y aurait une conférence au
sommet
je serai prêt à parler de cela
à mes amis messieurs Eisenhower et Mac
Millan et j'espère que Monsieur
Khrouchtchev
que j'ai naguère rencontré à Moscou dans
l'entourage de Staline et qui a fait
quelque chose depuis
voudra y prendre un terrain
messieurs vous ayant parlé de l'ensemble
de la situation internationale je me
livre à vous pour répondre dans la
mesure où je le pourrais
aux questions que vous voudrez me poser
sur des points particuliers
en général voici exactement 5 mois vous
avez lancé l'offre de la Paix des Braves
au rebelles algérien
comment jugez-vous que la situation est
évaluée en Algérie depuis lors
il est 130 ans que durent les
incertitudes algériennes
et
depuis quatre ans et plus
les combats et les attentats de
nous vivons à une époque
ou sur la terre
une colossale entreprise
s'oppose partout à l'Occident
tandis que l'Occident
néglige souvent de se soutenir lui-même
nous assistons au bouillonnement qui
à l'intérieur du monde musulman
oppose
mains pays arabes
à des peuples étrangers
et même des États et des fractions à
d'autres États et fractions de même race
et de même religion
et même
des tribuns à d'autres tribunes
qui comme eux et pourtant contre
se disent les champions de l'unité
dans ces conditions là je me demande si
quelqu'un
a jamais pu se figurer que la paix et la
prospérité
allez venir tout à coup à l'Algérie
ou qu'il suffirait de crier dans la
fièvre obsidionale un slogan contre
d'autres slogans pour que toutes les
causes intérieures et extérieurs de la
guerre actuelle disparaissent comme par
enchantement
cela je ne le pense pas
et je ne l'ai dit et je ne le dis jamais
mais je crois et je dis
que le destin de l'Algérie
dépend
d'une œuvre immense
qui durera qui sera une oeuvre de longue
haleine
et avant que les questions ne soient
décidément tranchées
mettre en cause l'effort de toute une
génération
je crois et je dis
que ce dont il s'agit
c'est que l'Algérie se révèle à
elle-même et qu'elle s'ouvre au monde
tel qu'il est
je crois et je dis que cette œuvre-là
est inimaginable sans la présence et
sans l'action de la France
je dis que la France a pris ses
résolutions
et
qu'elle a un plan n'était ferme qu'elle
suit ce plan
et qu'il s'agit pour elle avec les
Algériens
d'obtenir
la transformation de l'Algérie de telle
sorte que si révèle la personnalité
nouvelle de ce pays
pour cette transformation
qu'a-t-on fait
et bien depuis huit mois voici ce qu'on
a fait
au point de vue politique
la voix est ouverte
pour la première fois
et pour toujours
au suffrage égal et universel de tous
les Algériens qui disposent ainsi du
moyen pour aujourd'hui pour demain
d'exprimer leur volonté
des mesures irréversibles
ont créé un collège unique pour toutes
les femmes et tous les hommes de toutes
les catégories et de toutes les
communautés
et des mesures ont attribué aux
musulmans
la proportion la plus forte et de
beaucoup
dans les élus de toutes les
consultations
c'est sur cette base que c'est fait le
référendum de septembre
qui a montré d'une manière éclatante
que la machine mange du peuple algérien
excusez-moi me faisait confiance
pour lui donner
la paix
la liberté et la dignité et ainsi faire
en sorte que l'Algérie soit lié à la
France
des élections législatives ont eu lieu
le mois prochain les communes
algériennes et l'iront leurs conseils
municipaux
un peu plus tard
seront élus les conseils généraux
sans doute dit-on
que la situation de la guerre influe
plus ou moins sur l'objectivité de ces
diverses consultations
il n'en est pas moins vrai qu'elles ont
lieu
et que tous les Algériens savent
qu'ils ont ainsi le moyen de disposer de
même
à mesure de l'apaisement
que les représentations
n'ont plus aucun rapport avec ce
qu'elles étaient naguères
bref qu'une révolution
a été faite en Algérie si tenté qu'il y
en ait jamais eu une
au point de vue du développement
économique et lui salut social de
l'Algérie tout le monde a pu prendre
connaissance du commencement de
réalisation du plan
industriel et agricole de Constantine et
le Premier ministre pas plus tard
qu'hier en mettait une fois de plus en
lumière et donner
comme il arrive que quelquefois la
France et le progrès est ensemble de la
chance
il se trouve que la mise en exploitation
du pétrole et du gaz saharien
apporte justement au moment voulu
les moyens du démarrage
je dis aux Algériens regardez votre pays
tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui matériellement
et je vous réponds que bientôt
il sera très différent
au point de vue de l'instruction
c'est par centaines de milliers que
c'est accrue l'année dernière que sa
croix cette année que s'accroîtra
chacune des années prochaines
effective des écolières et des écoliers
algériens
si bien qu'avant 10 ans tous les enfants
il y en a beaucoup tous les enfants
iront en classe
et en même temps se développe
un effort de formation de cadre
administratif
technique
professionnelle militaire
et pour combien faut-il compter
les liens les relations qui vont se
multiplier entre la France tout entière
et l'Algérie tout entière
et dans lesquels l'armée
où je le dis en passant servent 110000
musulmans
l'armée joue un rôle capital
intellectuellement
socialement moralement l'Algérie est en
pleine gestation
il si forme une jeunesse y compris ceux
qui ont combattu dans les deux camps
une jeunesse qui voudra voir naître et
grandir une Algérie
nouvelle c'est-à-dire moderne
et fraternelle
cette transformation je le répète la
France a commencé de l'accomplir avec
les Algériens
c'est là une oeuvre magnifique
qui exige
l'effort de tous les Algériens
et l'effort des Français de France
en comparaison
le combat et les attentats acharnés
ils perdent
tout justification possible
il ne conduisent à rien
qu'à la misère
à la haine
à la mort
au fur et à mesure que l'Algérie
nouvelle
se dessinera
elle paraît son destin politique par
état dans l'esprit et dans les suffrages
de ses enfants
je n'en pas
mais je suis sûr
que les Algériens veulent les voudront
que le sort de l'Algérie soit lié à
celui de la France et je suis sûr
que la France ne voudra elle aussi
parce que ses conformes à la simple
nature des choses
au bon sens
et au sentiment
voilà ce que je peux dire sur ce qui
s'est passé en Algérie
au cours des derniers mois
et qui même si on l'aperçoit pas de
Paris tous les jours
en réalité est en train de se produire
oui
je vous en prie je m'excuse de vous
ramener à des problèmes
intérieurs et grâce mon matériel
nombre de Français sont aujourd'hui
mécontents et n'avons pas nous faire
leur déception c'est peut-être exprimé
dans certains des résultats des
élections municipales pouvez-vous nous
dire votre sentiment là-dessus
vous savez moi je ne me mêle absolument
pas de la conjoncture électorale
ça ne m'empêche pas de la juger
et à ce titre là je ne crois pas qu'on
puisse vraiment
comparer par exemple les résultats du
référendum avec ceux des élections
municipales
en septembre l'enjeu
c'était le changement de régime
et les élections législatives avaient pu
paraître confirmer cela
mais pour les élections municipales ils
n'ont été pas du tout de même il n'y
avait pas de grand intérêt national qui
fut en jeu
immédiatement et quant à moi je m'étais
une dans une totale partialité dans ces
conditions
il n'est pas très étonnant que un
certain nombre d'électeurs soient
retournés à la rubrique et qu'il
pratiquait précédemment cependant
je sais bien que
dans la presse on dit volontiers
que ce qui s'est passé tient d'abord à
la conjoncture financière et économique
et cela est vrai en grande partie
et puis aussi au fait que les pouvoirs
publics n'informe pas suffisamment les
citoyens du pourquoi et du comment des
choses
sur le premier point il est parfaitement
vrai que nous sommes dans une opération
très difficile et capitales de
redressement financier économique du
pays
se redressement je crois et vous aussi
qu'il est en train de réussir
évidemment et là cela ne peut aller sans
atteindre les intérêts particuliers même
tels ou tels intérêts qui sont modestes
parfaitement justifiable et parfaitement
respectable
alors
la mélancolie a pu en effet s'exprimer
de la manière que vous dites
quant au second point c'est à dire le
fait que le public ne serait pas très
bien informé
je constate que même quand les choses
sont très claires
excusez-moi messieurs les journalistes
même quand les choses sont très claires
elles ne sont pas toujours très bien mis
en vedette en général par les
informateurs car enfin toutes mes
nous pouvons maintenant
faire face à toutes les dépenses
publiques sans aucune espèce d'inflation
il y a 20 ans que ce n'est pas arrivé
la valeur de notre monnaie est un
contesté sur toutes les places du monde
un cadre à génère français n'a jamais vu
ça
nous avons
abaissé de 17% le taux du change de
notre franc
et en l'espace de trois mois les prix
n'ont pas monté de 4%
. alors que depuis Point Carré
toutes les dévaluations ont été suivies
d'une hausse massive des prix et d'une
nouvelle rupture d'équilibre
nous avons libéré à 90% nos échanges
extérieurs
et
cependant la balance commerciale et la
balance des comptes sont en or ce qui
constitue n'est-ce pas une étonnante
innovation
au lieu de quitter la France les
capitaux viennent s'y employer en 10
semaines plus de 300 milliards de francs
si bien que le mot plus besoin de
demander des secours à d'autres et même
nous payons nos dettes
il y a la me semble-t-il des points
essentiels qui pourraient c'est mon avis
être mis mieux en valeur
et qui sont tout à fait notoires
et puis
je constate
qu'on insiste volontiers
sur les côtés pénibles de l'entreprise
comme par exemple
l'annonce indexation renoncée des pays
des produits agricoles
ou bien
l'abattement de 3000 francs sur les
remboursements de la sécurité sociale
ou bien le nom paiement de leur retraite
aux anciens combattants qui ne sont ni
Invalides
ni économiquement faible etc
mais on ne parle que très rarement des
mesures qui sont prises en contrepartie
comme par exemple l'augmentation des
prix d'objectifs agricoles
l'augmentation de 4 et demi pour cent du
salaire minimum garanti
l'augmentation de 4 % des traitements et
des salaires de la fonction et des
services publics
l'augmentation de 5200 francs de la
retraite et vieilles gens
l'effort accompli pour la construction
des forces supplémentaires accomplies
pour la construction de logements pour
l'aménagement des localités pour la
destruction des taudis etc
on insiste beaucoup
et souvent
sur une certaine récession qui se fait
sentir dans quelques branches
d'activités et qui suscite des
inquiétudes
il y a la fête mondiale moins sensible
chez nous qu'ailleurs vous le savez mais
cependant très pénible pour beaucoup
et
auquel le gouvernement doit appliquer
toutes les dispositions possibles
mais justement le gouvernement implique
ces dispositions là
et peut-être pourrait-on les faire
valoir un peu mieux
car enfin il est parfaitement vrai que
l'État a cru de plus de 25 % cette année
le total des sommes qui consacrent aux
investissements
il y a eu une impulsion qui a été donnée
à l'intéressement des travailleurs à la
marche des entreprises
il y a une organisation qui a été
instituée commune au syndicat et au
patronat pour la garantie de l'emploi
et pour le paiement le cas échéant d'une
indemnité complémentaire de chômage tout
cela encore une fois pourraient être je
vous livre ma pensée
mise en valeur un peu mieux dans nos
journaux
la liberté
d'écrire et de publier est un droit
à ceux qui
en prennent la responsabilité
il est loisible je le proclame
de suer le ciel ou de cracher le
vinaigre tout autant que de distribuer
le lait ou de répandre le miel
cependant je dois puisque l'occasion
m'en est offerte je dois attirer
l'attention sur un point
le plan de redressement économique qui
est en cours
on ne pourrait pas facilement
le modifier même au cas où on le
voudrait
c'est qu'en effet il résulte d'une
ordonnance qui a été prise en vertu des
plats pouvoirs délégués par la nation
et qui a promulgué le budget de 1959
pour
remettre en question l'ensemble de ce
budget
il faudrait donc remettre en cause
la délégation elle-même c'est à dire
procéder à un référendum ou à des
élections nouvelles je ne vois pas
quelle autre procédure aurait justifié
cette modification profonde de
l'ordonnance dont j'ai parlé et qui
résulte encore une fois d'une délégation
exprès c'est former les directs du
peuple français
sous cet angle là comme sur beaucoup
d'autres
il me paraît qu'il vaut beaucoup mieux
que le plan réussisse
et ben justement c'est ce qui est en
train de nous arriver
oui en général pouvez-vous nous
commenter la décision de garder la
langue française
et aussi de nous expliquer un peu en
général les idées de gouvernement
français sur la rayonisation avec
éventuelle
je vous dirais que ça ne me paraît pas
être le moment ni le lieu
d'expliquer dans son ensemble la façon
dont la France juge que doit être
organisée la sécurité mondiale et
l'Alliance atlantique
et je me borne
à vous répondre sur un point particulier
qui a été évoqué dans l'opinion publique
celui de
la France reprenant la disposition de sa
flotte
de la Méditerranée pour le temps de
guerre
je fais observer que la zone d'action
éventuelle de l'OTAN ne s'étend pas au
sud de la Méditerranée
le moyen-organ l'Afrique du Nord
l'Afrique noire Madagascar la mer Rouge
etc etc n'en font pas partie tout le
monde sait cela
mais on ne peut pas contester que la
France puisse avoir
un moment ou un autre et à quelques
moments que ce soit
agir dans ces contrées
et comment le ferait-elle dans le cadre
de l'OTAN
et d'autre part comment le prêt-elle si
elle disposait pas de sa flotte
commence en s'a flotte pourrait-elle
mener quelle action que ce soit dans les
pays dont je viens de parler ou pour les
défendre
j'observe d'ailleurs que pour des
raisons évidemment analogue les deux
autres grandes puissances de l'Alliance
c'est-à-dire les États-Unis et la
Grande-Bretagne ont pris leur
disposition pour que la plus grande part
de leur force navale ne soit pas
intégrée dans l'actuel au temps
et en outre elle garde ses deux
puissances garde dans leur seulement
l'élément essentiel de leur force c'est
à dire les bombardiers atomiques
quant au fait que la France est repris
la disposition de la flotte
je ne crois pas du tout que ça puisse
l'empêcher le cas échéant et d'engager
la flotte dans la bataille commune en
Méditerranée
et je ne vois pas que l'Alliance
atlantique en soit affaibli et je crois
même le contraire
parce que
il me semble
et que cette alliance sera d'autant plus
vivante et d'autant plus forte que les
grands États qui en font partie
s'uniront
sur la base de la coopération
où chacun apporte sa charge
plutôt que sur celle de l'intégration
ou les États et les peuples et les
gouvernements
ne se voit dans la matière sacrée et de
leur propre défense
dépouillez peu ou proue de leur rôle et
de leur responsabilité
tout à l'heure que le gouvernement
français envisageait comme un acte de
stabilité tout interdiction de passage
du tout occidental à Berlin si vous
précisez votre pensée sur ce point et
nous dire si vous croyez que la tête
conflit puisse rester localisé et où au
contraire de la naissance à un conflit
généralisé
quelle serait l'attitude de la France au
cas où les alliés ne représentait
moi je ne cherche pas à rassurer
personne je vois les choses comme elles
sont je crois que si dans l'état actuel
du monde des actes hostiles s'engagaient
on ne voit pas trop comment il serait
possible de les limiter en tout cas
c'est une aventure
il vaut peut-être mieux se dire les uns
aux autres par les mois d'amour
et intégration au sein de l'OTAN est-ce
que vous pourriez dire si vous envisagez
de faire la même chose
je voudrais faire
avec des unités de l'homme et de terre
ou de la médaille
mais vous le verrez bien
pour ce qui est pour ce qui est de la
flotte je viens vous expliquer bien vous
expliquer où en sont les choses et
qu'elles en sont les raisons dans le cas
où il se produirait d'autres changements
vous en seriez certainement d'informer
d'une rencontre éventuelle entre vous
mon général et le roi du Maroc est-ce
que vous pourriez nous dire ce qu'il y a
de vrai ce qu'il y a de fonder dans ce
groupe
et bien vous avez pu voir
comment sa Majesté le Roi du Maroc a
exprimer publiquement d'ailleurs
l'idée qu'il y aura un avantage
pour les deux étapes
à une rencontre éventuelle
des deux chefs d'État
et je puis vous dire ce n'est pas un
mystère que je suis en dans l'ensemble
dans un sentiment identique à celui de
Sa Majesté le Roi du Maroc
alors quand au moment quand au modalités
quant au sujet de cette éventuel
entretien vous comprendrez que je ne
puisse pas vous répondre
mais ce que je peux dire c'est que de
part et d'autre les choses sont
envisagées dans un sentiment de sincère
et profonde amitié
le gouvernement accepte le principe de
négociation directe avec le FLN
qu'est-ce que vous appelez une
négociation directe
de la façon la plus formelle et la plus
solennel hier et avant-hier en Algérie
que l'offre que j'avais fait pour le
cesser le feu au mois d'octobre
était toujours valable à intégralement
je ne crois pas qu'il soit utile que je
le réduise une facture c'est bien clair
et bien certain
j'ajoute même que à mon sens
pourquoi on en viendrait-on pas là
puisque de toute façon d'une manière ou
d'une autre c'est comme ça que ça finira
et bien monsieur je suis heureux de vous
avoir vu j'espère avoir satisfait à
l'essentiel de ce qui est votre
curiosité votre souci d'information je
vous remercie de m'avoir prêté votre
aimable attention au revoir mesdames et
messieurs
[Musique]